la parole est au président et jean
pierre raffarin dans le groupe est
républicain vous avez la parole monsieur
prix si monsieur le président monsieur
le premier ministre mesdames messieurs
les ministres dans ces circonstances
graves vous pouvez aussi compter
monsieur le premier ministre sur notre
groupe pour rester rassemblés autour des
valeurs de la vème république
ces institutions auxquelles nous sommes
attachés et nous voyons bien
qu'aujourd'hui il nous faut nous
rassembler autour de ces institutions
hier en congrès l'homme en charge de
l'essentiel pour reprendre l'expression
du général de gaulle parlant du
président la république nous a annoncé
un fort changement dans politique
étrangère notamment en ce qui concerne
la situation en syrie
trois sujets deux sont très claires
premièrement la définition de l'ennemi
c'est clair l'ennemi c'est l'état
islamique
nous avons hiérarchiser nos adversité et
maintenant nous voulons une stratégie
sur un territoire avec un adversaire
nous sortons neal h
les bachar deuxièmement le périmètre de
l'alliance c'est aussi clair nous
voulons qu'il y ait une seule coalition
ça veut dire qu'il faut que la russie
intègre de manière à ce que nous soyons
rassemblés sur le terrain le troisième
point c'est la solution politique
la solution politique mais surprise
c'est ma première question que pensez
vous des négociations de vienne où
allons nous et notamment sur le point
qui me paraît le point clé comment
peut-on associer les sunnites à
l'exercice des responsabilités dans le
territoire syrien
enfin monsieur le premier ministre quel
bilan tirez-vous de nos frappes
militaires sur ce terrain là nous avons
besoin de réponses précises car nous
sommes engagés dans une bataille qui
exige l'efficacité les récentes frappes
ont été spectaculaires
pouvez vous nous dire quels sont les
résultats et le bilan que vous faites de
notre action militaire contre d'âge
merci
on vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre c'est au
président monsieur le premier ministre
j'aime votre engagement le rappel des
principes républicains la solidité de
nos institutions
celle de la vème république et le fait
que dans ces moments là le chef de
l'état incarne effectivement l'essentiel
je crois que c'est un cycle de l'avons
ressenti hier et au delà du congrès nos
compatriotes
l'ennemi c'est dèche n'avons jamais
changé de position l'ennemi c'est neige
puisque nous avons été visé par l'état
islamique par des ch au mois de janvier
cette organisation a voulu nous frapper
nous a frappés parce que nous sommes la
france un peuple debout qui parle au
monde un peuple libre et nous avons
décidé dès 2014
vous savez d'être dans une coalition à
laquelle nous avons contribué pour
frapper l'état islamique pour frapper
des ch en irak avec le soutien d'un
certain nombre de nos amis traditionnels
de pays de la région à la demande du
pouvoir irakien avec le soutien bien sûr
aussi des kurdes et avec des résultats
sur le terrain même si nous avons
toujours dit ce serait long et difficile
et qu'il fallait d'abord contenir des ch
avec un rappel qui doit être fait sans
cesse c'est que l'épicentre de dèche
l'épicentre de l'état islamique
c'est en irak c'est là où il est d'abord
née du démembrement de l'irak les
conséquences de l'intervention
américaine également et mossoul et leur
capital vous souvenez pas un village
vous le savez c'est sans doute trois
cent mille habitants et des moyens
financiers tout à fait considérable
qu'ils ont accaparé et qui nourrissent
aujourd'hui le terrorisme
nous avons décidé il ya encore quelques
semaines malgré les difficultés que cela
peut représenter vu la situation en
syrie de frapper en syrie de frapper des
ch
puisque c'est ça toujours notre objectif
c'est l'ennemi j'étais moi même il ya
quelques semaines avec le ministre de la
défense jean yves le drian au caire à
ryad en jordanie et nous avons dit
exactement nous avons repris vos propos
ceux du président de la république hier
des chaussées notre ennemi et donc nous
continuerons à frapper ce le premier
ministre vous connaissez suffisamment
ces questions à ce stade mais le
ministre de la défense se tient bien sûr
à votre disposition les objectifs que
nous frappons notamment à jaca des
centres de commandement des camps
d'entraînement sont des objectifs que
nous avons définies je ne doute pas des
résultats que nos avions obtenu mais je
veux rester à ce stade
prudent et discret vu les circonstances
et vu que nous avons d'autres frappes à
effectuer deuxièmement sur le périmètre
des alliances
s'il ya un changement ce n'est pas celui
de la diplomatie française ce sont les
faits eux mêmes qui l'ont imposé
vendredi dans la nuit à paris c'est la
prise de conscience de ce qui s'est
passé dans toute une série de capitales
série d'attentats non seulement en
france mais également dans un certain
nombre de pays bien sûr en turquie au
liban
l'avion russe l'avion de ces compagnies
russes vous avez remarqué les fins
observateurs que c'est ce matin même que
le gouvernement russe a considéré qu'il
s'agissait d'un attentat ce qui n'avait
pas été le cas jusqu'à maintenant je ne
doute pas que les russes ont décidé
désormais de frapper des shs de
d'intervenir dans cette partie là de
bombarder ce qui aussi est important ce
qui est un vrai changement
car jusqu'à maintenant les frappes russe
concernait d'abord l'opposition à bachar
el-assad dans la partie syrienne est
tous très souvent ce qu'on appelle
l'opposition modérée
donc moi je veux saluer
sans doute aussi ce changement est vu
cette situation le président de la
république considère qu'il ya là en
effet une opportunité opportunités
nouvelles que nous devons saisir que
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale doit saisir
d'où aussi la résolution que nous
voulons proposer au conseil de sécurité
les rencontres auront lieu la semaine
prochaine avec les président poutine et
obama pour créer les conditions de cette
de cette coalition de cette coalition
unique chacun à condition que chacun
ils prennent sa place non seulement les
deux grandes puissances que nous avons
évoqués mais aussi les états de la
région parce que sans eux rien n'est
possible et je ne veux pas oublier non
plus le soutien nécessaire aux kurdes
qui se battent sur le terrain avec une
vaillance tout à fait extraordinaire
enfin la solution politique
personne ne peut penser à terme je dis
bien à terme
personne ne peut penser à terme qu'on
trouvera une solution dans cette région
dans le levant marqué par cette division
entre sunnites et chiites
personne ne peut penser que cette
solution peut passer par le maintien de
bachar el-assad est long
toute solution politique devra intégrer
cet élément c'est le sens du processus
de vienne
il y avait en effet une réunion à
laquelle participaient laurent fabius
samedi dernier ces résultats ne sont
sans doute pas encore à la hauteur de ce
que nous pourrions espérer mais la
constitution d'une coalition large sur
le plan militaire permettra je n'en
doute pas également de faire avancer le
processus politique indispensable entre
les éléments du régime et l'opposition
modérée
voilà monsieur le premier ministre je
crois que c'est clair
l'ennemi c'est des shs la nécessité
d'avoir une coalition large à laquelle
la france va pleinement contribué déjà
par ses frappes mais par les initiatives
du président de la république et la
nécessité de voir long terme car trop
souvent dans les interventions qui ont
été menées ces dernières années en irak
ou en libye s'il y a une victoire
militaire dans un premier temps l'erreur
la faux
stratégique c'est de ne pas avoir pensé
la suite et nous commettrions une faute
stratégique
si nous en tenions uniquement aux
frappes et une opération militaire sans
penser à la suite et notamment aux
séries monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre
on emploie beaucoup dans ces
circonstances le mot de guerre si on
parle de guerre il faut aller jusqu'au
bout parce qu'une guerre de cette nature
ça se gagne
ou c'est le malheur et donc il faut une
efficacité et un rassemblement sur le
terrain absolument essentiel pour gagner
il faudra aussi plus de sécurité sur
notre propre territoire
car on ne peut pas faire la guerre à
jaca et expliquer qu'en france on va
être tranquille et qu'on va pouvoir
vivre sans cette conscience de la
sécurité
il nous faudra tous ensemble dans le
rassemblement des institutions de la
vème république met notre action à la
hauteur de notre vocabulaire
merci